foreign
[Music]
what's going on guys we we are back at
it again
you guys know that is r r with the Lords
of me and King David talking about
everything TV entertainment related
anime related whatever you guys could
think of we're talking about it so here
with my co-host with me I don't even
think that's a cause and host of this
thing but I'm here with King David
what's going on King
oh attic what's going on I've been
looking forward to this one this this
I don't know
um since the eight hour marathon on
Sunday
it's a really heartwarming and stuff
like that
um kind of crazy kind of crazy eight
hours but you know the love was
incredible I needed it I needed it but I
also needed some of these movies that I
had to go see and some of the stuff that
I had to go check out
yeah so uh you know I've watched a
little bit when it comes to movies this
week
um but not like a whole lot I've been
doing like a lot of IOP stuff but we're
gonna get into a couple of the things
you know we got
our show for you today is we're gonna
talk about rinfall is that what it's
called
Renfield Renfield we're gonna talk about
Renfield
we have some good bars we're going to
talk about um
Marvel what's going on with uh Jonathan
over there uh you know the the future
with him in the franchise
yeah Jonathan majors and we're gonna
talk about beef the TV show that's on
Netflix
uh so you know first off let's let's get
into uh the the business portion of it
uh we
I once again you know everyone that's
watching now you know if you're anime
fans definitely go over there and sub to
the patreon I've pretty much got almost
up to date my hero stuff going on over
there right now
Saul was about to uh I think I'm gonna
have him react to the moderate versus
the Allied Forces this weekend
oh that'll be good yeah that was a good
one yeah that's going to be interesting
and then I think after that I might have
him react like agar versus Rock Lee or
something like that and then I'm gonna
have him start reacting to the death
note franchise uh so that's over there
at
you know patreon definitely go over
there and check that out I think you
guys are going to really enjoy that King
is currently reacting to season two on
Attack on Titan I think I'm going to
start like picking up some smaller
animes because I won't I
look sure we'll probably get the most
benefit from reacting to bigger animes
but I think we you know we do have a
little bit of a voice in terms of just
the channel size and not necessarily r r
but everything where I feel like I want
to get some of these smaller animes you
know these animes that people always say
is really good I'm going to give them a
little bit of a try you know react to
them live go over it
um you know a lot of that's going to be
done on the patreon because the issue
that we have with this is we can do the
podcast on here but we don't want to mix
and match too much of the entertainment
anime stuff with the gaming stuff so
unfortunately if you want to see you
know some of the in-depth stuff you have
to go to patreon you know I've
considered making this patreon but we're
not going to do that you know we we
really want to give back to you guys uh
you know we haven't really ruled
anything out but anyway
let's get on with the first thing I
think the biggest thing we need to talk
about right now King is the Marvel thing
you know wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait what do you want to talk about
first I want to talk about what I've
been watching now um is that the whole
point of the topics yeah yeah yeah but I
had a topic up there that's not up there
so I want to get into that first before
we can get into all other stuff that's
up there
um I'm watching uh this King Vaughn from
uh trap law Ross it's a three-hour
documentary that's up there and um
anybody that follows uh trap law Ross uh
you know this now I'm not picking a side
in uh the documentary I'm just gonna
talk about the documentary and I follow
him heavy um I have this weird addiction
to documentaries now a lot of people
um
you know some people follow like serial
killers and you remember when the the
Ted Bundy thing was popping and uh what
was that guy that uh eight people
um Jeffrey Dahmer thing was going on
Netflix and everybody had like this
weird addiction to that stuff whoa but I
think the reason that people gravitated
for that so much is because the person
actually played a well Jeffrey Dahmer I
think if you would have went in there
horrible acting no one would have talked
about but the problem was is you know
they didn't really focus on him they
focused on his victims so you didn't you
glorified him but you didn't at the same
time and I feel like the people they
casted did the job so well that that's
why people were talking about it but to
get to that part they had to go through
you know the real life stuff like the
real life documentaries right
and um I'm one of those dudes that watch
all type of documentaries I'll probably
watch documentaries on nature
but the documentaries that uh actually
uh Captivate me the most are
really Hood documentaries and this guy
trapped Laurel Ross it's he's probably
one of the best that does it
uh right now and what's kind of crazy is
he's not from the urban environment like
the environment that I grew up as as a
child so to document the stuff that he
does from a distance and get down and
gritty with it as much as he does
um
it's it's it's really really incredible
to see so
um this this documentary that he drops
on King Vaughn is hip-hop's first serial
killer and
uh uh the way that he presents it he
presents it in such a fashion and he he
documents all the the history of it and
he peace he's piecing together
um you know murders and and and stuff
like that and also chronalizing uh
chronicalizing the timelines
it's
a masterful piece of work done by uh
traplo Ross in getting that across you
know the music is captivating yeah
because they you know they talk about
the music but a lot of people don't know
the artists uh behind the artist like
the the how the artist got to that space
and how that he got so much notoriety
and he explains it so eloquently
um
not not saying that you know anything
was right or wrong it's just uh the way
that he does the documentary was
fantastic and you know um if anybody's
interested in that stuff you can go up
to uh trap law Ross on YouTube catch
that stuff there really compelling stuff
uh but also remember it's on the the
darker side because we're talking about
real life stuff that's happened and
people are really affected by uh the
things that are allegedly perpetrated
from this individual uh music is what's
the music speaks to if you're into uh
Chicago drill music uh that's that's
there but um it was just something that
I'm I I get kind of caught up in and I
watch so that's a real good something to
watch if you're into documentaries go
check that out uh I gave that
documentary probably full popcorn I
thought it was in an incredible insight
into the mind of an urban uh alleged
serial killer so really incredible stuff
yeah I feel like me back up a little bit
see the the space works I don't want see
if I get too far away people say I'm in
the only fans video if I get too close I
think what is the white wall I think
it's the white wall I think what I'm
gonna do is buy like a like a Zelda
poster or something put it on there I
don't know you have your green screen
you can do a billion things with it but
then I have to move my desk up a little
bit and like put the green screen right
like I don't know I'll look into it I'll
look into it it's a lot of work to put
that green screen in there
I feel you so you know what I've been
watching is
he's been watching can you guys can you
guys hear that TV nope oh you can't hear
that TV at all
I hit something minor all right well I
told her to turn it down a little bit
just yeah I heard something very minor
because like the living room is right
here but these are decent mics they have
a really good noise canceling so all
right so I I watched this movie called
life it's on Hulu it's about um
these astronauts go to Mars and
they pick up a life force it's like a
little microscopic life force but it
gets bigger and the more and want to eat
something or combines with it it gets
bigger
that's the one when they're in space
right yes
I think I saw that one um creature looks
crazy
and it's like uh it starts off like it's
like a Venom type of thing right yes
yeah I saw that one yeah it was a good
movie though and you know I watched um
he said the battle Angel that's on Hulu
ethica or I don't know someone in the
chat I know you know what I'm talking
about uh it's it's the the pixelated
movie where it's about
um artificial intelligence it's a CGI
movie where she's a robot and she has
the big eyes no yeah the big eyes and
she she yeah and they have a rolling uh
like a roller derby type of thing and
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um you talking about
um Whatchamacallit battle Angel that's
uh that comes from a anime uh that's
really good to be honest yeah it's
really cool
2019 and yeah I was like there's no way
there's no way they're doing anything
else with this franchise like because
usually when it comes to movies if you
don't see anything in three years it's
over it's a rap they're not doing
anything with it anymore but I looked it
up and uh it was updated this year that
they they said that they're right now
like in the beginning yeah
they're in the beginning phages to
making the sequel and you know what it
you know what I bet you it was King
I bet you it was that Tick Tock the
shorts content because that's how I
found it was through Tech talk shorts
content literally I have I have a
hashtag I follow on Tick Tock that
literally just shows me nothing yes
that shows me nothing but movies
it's like it would be like a part of a
movie like a little bit of part of a
movie uh so sometimes when I'm bored I
just click it and I just scroll through
it what looks interesting what looks
interesting you know that fall movie
that you that I try to get you to watch
a couple weeks a couple months ago
that's where I found that that's where I
found um The Life movie
yeah Lita Lita was really good it was a
real deep story uh I mean it has a lot
of content because like I said before as
an anime uh so they're just going to uh
probably rewrite the ending because
that's not how the ending goes you know
with them trying to get up to the clouds
um that's not how the ending goes uh but
it'll probably like rewrite the ending
and tell you a little bit more uh about
it and probably going to more of the
animes but yeah that stuff is really
good really good stuff
yeah I think it was good so you know
look let's move on with the show man
first off sir put the patreon in the
chat so you guys can definitely go there
um you know hopefully we'll get some
more King reactions here soon I don't
know if we're gonna usually we record
that after the show I don't know if he
has time today
um maybe we'll get episode of two but uh
we're gonna go ahead and move on to the
Jonathan
Dudu plus guy you know
did you see what's going on here a
hundred percent
well what would uh Jonathan Mages
Jonathan Majors like he was dropped by
his agency and his management team
management how does the management drop
you
um I find it weird
because the reasons that they gave that
was they they said that it was his uh
conduct
um
his work in relationship conduct
I find it kind of weird
right because
I see
they're not comparing apples to oranges
not getting into the crimes itself I'm
just getting into the individuals right
and just talking about the individuals
Ezra Miller has uh done some felonious
things that's the guy that plays The
Flash
right over at Warner Brothers
um
breaking and entering allegedly
kidnapping assault uh
uh he's been out a lot of things you
know to to
a total Menace total minutes he's he's
been a villain absolute villain
that's the funny part
right he said I think they miscast him
um Jonathan Mages and not to make light
of whatever the situation is I'm just
talking about uh an alleged crime
uh
gets into something domestically with an
individual that he's with uh
and there's a huge ton of backlash
and I feel I have to say that I mean
hate to pull a race card but I believe
that there's a racial component to go
with this thing here
um because you know Ezra Miller was
dealing with minors this this
is absolutely mind-blowing I think that
is mainly on the WB aspect uh you know I
think Disney's quicker to pull the
trigger they got rid of Johnny Depp they
got rid of um what's that other thing
Disney Disney
didn't say anything about it though this
is I mean this is his management team
well see I I guess to their degree their
mind well see it's the Disney thing but
they're already like there's reports
already that they're they're rewriting
scripts they're already trying to get
rid of Jonathan well they're talking
about recast and I mean there's rumors
that but you as a as a giant Corporation
you're supposed to do these thoughts
deep thoughts right you're supposed to
have these questions about somebody it's
integral to your uh your plans going
forward and if they happen to arise in
trouble you gotta
approach the conversation in either
removal replacement or whatever that
comes to this guy I just find it insane
because on May 8th is where he actually
you know goes to court
for this thing so I don't know if the
state gonna pick it up
um because I don't believe that the
girlfriend is pressing charges I believe
the girlfriend recanted uh her statement
uh to the police the funny thing is the
moment that happened it should have been
a wrap like yeah what's crazy is he got
penalized for those allegations the day
they happen because that was crazy right
um he had military uh you know
commercials he was supposed to do and
then you talk about the Army commercials
yeah so it's just like dude
I I'm just I'm just so
there's scenarios
where they have pulled people off for
like like it's like the Johnny Depp
thing he was literally cast for multiple
Disney projects multiple he was supposed
to come back as Johnny Depp he was in
the Harry Potter franchise at the time
with uh WB which is funny they got
Johnny Depp up out of there but not
Israel Miller it's like Ezra Miller has
has dirt on them like he's like no you
ain't getting rid of me he's like I'm
taking you with me because they got rid
of Johnny Depp up out of there like like
no pass go no click 200 and you know
what's funny I looked the cells of the
first um because I didn't understand I
knew that there was like a sequel to the
Harry Potter a prequel to The Harry
Potter franchise but I didn't realize
what they did in it because I didn't
watch it for years later and then I went
back and looked up all the the drama and
stuff happened to it like after I think
about the um the the what's one called
incredible bees yeah after they did that
to Johnny Depp the franchise bombed like
every one of them bombed after that I
think they made one or two movies after
that it's just like dude like people
need to start realizing if you could
have come at some of these huge in some
of these huge actors that have millions
and millions of Fallout fans because of
stuff they did like like um you know
Pirates of the Caribbean there's going
to be consequences when you take them
out of your movies now but the Johnny
Depp thing I think that was on a greater
scale because you had an actual uh
alleged victim
uh uh accusing a huge star two huge
Stars
accusing one one accusing them him of uh
of the misappropriateness and
Johnny had to fight like for his name
and all allegations that were uh coming
out was insane it was insane stuff you
have video footage it was it was a huge
drama that was wrapped around the Johnny
Depp stuff so I mean I all we got is a
police report
uh and two recounted uh uh
pieces of work that's on the police
report and and that's about it but this
guy has been uh crucified you know I
think that's a huge work uh has been
excoriated in the the the the realm of
public opinion when it comes to this
case and it's kind of crazy because he
didn't even go in front of a judge yet
which he would in you know May 8th but
to get dropped by your management team
he's made the most money right now he
has two we had two movies which charted
number one
and I think I think what it is
here's the thing it's crazy as much as I
want to blame the company's doing I
can't blame the companies I have to
blame the outcry of I feel like
companies should stand their ground more
but
sometimes these companies look at the
bottom line like look you know are we
gonna lose other clients because they
feel like us working with this
individual might cost them money and I
get it it's unfair and I think that you
know the the cancer culture thing is
ridiculous because I honestly feel like
cancer culture is okay just we're
canceling the wrong people
yeah and the people that can be canceled
that should be canceled their fan base
don't care
so you can't the only thing that
canceling culture really does is scare
people into giving sponsorships and to
giving money into giving hosting
opportunities the problem is is when
you're self-sufficient and you can make
your money without any of those things
you cannot be canceled
and the people that are in the
situations that do the most grimies as
[__]
are in situations where it doesn't
matter if they're canceled
some of these corporations no you got to
think about it right I don't I never
heard of Ezra Miller's team um his
management team dropping him
this this is that's the stuff that I'm
talking about I feel you on that but I
feel this guy was going yeah I'm not
disagreeing with you on that I honestly
feel like something's up there because
you gotta have dirt they they've gotten
rid of people for less like the
allegation of Johnny Depp was able to
get him out there I remember even though
it turned out to be true what's that do
from House of Cards
even though that that wasn't proven at
the time the moment those allegations
were met they got him up out of there so
it's just like it's crazy that Ezra
Miller as they would have been like it's
like he's Superman in the cancer culture
like he's like he's the flash for real
like you can't touch him it's like you
keep going back in time but let me I I
did just check the patreon uh we do have
a patreon question so let me get this
patreon question real quick I'm gonna
have to because someone said you got to
zoom the words up see the problem is is
when I'm so far back I have to zoom it
up because the the monitor is way over
here you know what I'm saying Hey yo uh
Ahoy Lord King and Lord addict with the
speculation of Mando's death I didn't
know the speculation around that but
anyway
or or of Bio Katana taking over who's
Katana
yeah how do the Lords see the movie is
Disney just loving all these elves
they're getting lately or do they just
wanna
want another show to collapse into
itself as always love y'all and stay on
that hustle that 300th episode put a
fire in me to start producing my own
stuff and throwing it out in The Ether
thank you for all that you uh thank uh
thank you all for that Vegeta is still
the goat okay I don't know about that
last one but I don't know about Vegeta
being a goat but um
Okay so
uh you want to go first so I didn't know
they're expecting like Commando dying
all right so so are we the chick the the
one have you have you caught up on that
I've seen the last I've seen one episode
uh I'm I'm an episode behind I'm gonna
watch that one I just saw the one when
it was on the planet with the Rogue
robots all right so I don't have my uh
steam that I'm about to spoil something
a couple episodes ago so uh mute for a
couple seconds
um no Mando's not dead it's speculation
we're not spoiling that all right so you
want me to just
no no not you you should have seen this
this is like three episodes ago huh this
is three episodes you should have seen
this it's oh okay you said three
episodes as well yeah it happened a
couple episodes ago
um where
the dark saver
right
who has the dark saver where you're at
uh he just gave it to Boca time okay
that's that's what I'm talking about
right now so we're talking Boca that's
the chick right the one that's supposed
to take over yeah that happens I'm gonna
be upset if they kill
Mando to give her the rain I get it
technically it makes sense in the way
things are going but I don't like it all
right he he beat her fair and square to
get the sword right to to get the the
Ebony Blade to get to get the dark saber
uh and you know um because he uh beat
this guy he beat
um
oh what's this guy uh uh the the the the
fake uh Darth Sidious guy the uh the
black guy anyway um he beats him gets
the the darksaber and he fights her and
she loses and he beat her in real Combat
now when he lost to that creature and
got captured and Grogan went and got her
technically the right of the the saber
went to that creature when she beat the
creature
um she basically had the right to it
right okay
the the lore behind the dark saber is
it chooses the wielder correct
yeah
he doesn't know how to weld because
notice when she went in there to save
him
she was using that thing like a
lightsaber like right she she knows how
to like the same thing like um with the
welder the welder was trying to explain
to him how he had to relax and how he
had to become one with the dark saber in
order to use the dark saber but anyway
she is taxed with bringing back the
fleet of the mandalorians and then going
back bringing them back to the
cul-de-sac where the other mandalorians
that follow the way
because these mandalorians are not of
the way but they have Mandalorian blood
she beats that guy in combat she shows
the sword uh the the the darksaber if
they follow her now they go back to the
cul-de-sac because this is what's
supposed to happen I didn't see anything
else after that episode but she's
supposed to go back to the cul-de-sac
bring them back there and then they're
supposed to go back to Mandalore to
repopulate mandolin actually I'm okay
with them Shifting the show a little bit
to her I'm just not okay with them
killing man though you know what oh no
no I'm not I'm not they
all right Disney has been on some uh
feminist stuff for a while
not a huge fan of it right I'm not a
huge fan of taking it and making
everything uh female Centric uh when it
comes to a lot of characters I think a
lot of characters
um don't need that right if if you want
to do a boca time uh a storyline do a
boca time storyline don't hijack Mando
in order to tell your story that's my
opinion of it but I don't believe they
kill Mando in order to further push Bo
Katan I don't believe that happens I
don't believe that's in Disney cards I
believe they understand that the
Mandalorian and and uh Den Duren is a a
good character within itself and he he
is that that space uh Cowboy that
they're looking for so I don't think
they kill him I don't think so at all I
just don't want them doing that because
I personally feel like he's been the
star of the show and it would make it
would be very weird I'm okay with them
Shifting the Mandalore to like
respecting her to following her and
slowly now that that storyline's been
established they start to to separate
him from that storyline you know what
I'm saying and then that storyline gets
Revisited later
but to me killing him and letting her
take the reins I have an issue with
because I feel like that is agenda
pushing yeah I don't think I don't think
they do that um they have to separate
this they have to you know remember he
needs he has a lot of offers all over
the place where him and baby grogle can
actually go and live right so
do you think that
it's just straight up like people just
fear it so they're doing it
yeah
yeah all right so yeah we'll go ahead
and get on with the the next one we gave
you guys that patreon goodness all right
so rip rip filled all right don't tell
me man I didn't see it that's my move
what
it's dope my my movie theater is playing
um uh playing Mario again like okay the
one that the the little mama papa one
that's been building because my mind
closed down they've like restructured
they got like a bunch of money like
they're trying to build their theater
bigger and better you know what I'm
saying and uh the 21st they're playing
Mario I'm gonna go watch it again
I'm actually going to go see it tomorrow
I'm taking my son to go see it so tell
me about this show man
all right so uh
Nicholas Cage is cast in a role of
Dracula
right and they go all the way back to
Boris Karloff as Dracula I felt found
Boris Karloff to be like the best
Dracula uh a lot of the Hallmarks they
have like when you look into his eyes
and all you know all that stuff but the
stories being told by Renfield his
servant his servant that is always a
with uh Dracula and you know renfield's
always eating bugs and always doing
things and they give you the law behind
Renfield eating bunks the law is that
Dracula gave him some of his blood and
he's he's Dracula's familiar and as
being as Dracula's familiar you are
tasked to do Dracula's bidding get him
this get him that but they attack it
from a different aspect of it so what
Renfield was doing and this is
renfield's story not Dracula's story but
Dracula is a huge part in the story
because Renfield is co-dependent on
Dracula he has a co-dependent
relationship and he goes to like a a a
relation uh um meeting where he listens
to people's stories and when he's
listening to these people's stories he's
finding out that you know like wow
Dracula's a narcissist and this whole
time I've been being manipulated to do
his bidding and he's controlling me and
he's listening to these people talk
about their lives now what Renfield was
doing was instead of bringing Dracula
uh like uh good people often like nuns
and cheerleaders and stuff like that he
was in these meetings to to find the
people that are harming the guys talking
so like if a lady is talking about her
boyfriend beating her up he gets all the
information goes find the boyfriend put
chloroform on them and bring some back
to Dracula Dracula is in the process of
rebuilding his body because he got
horrifically burnt
um and he's bringing him these bodies to
get in control now there's a crime
family that's there the movie is so over
the top because Nicholas Cage acting is
over the top so all the bloody scenes is
over the top uh and it stars the girl
did you um see
what was that um movie and and attention
uh Shang Chi uh from Disney you saw that
the Marvel movie yeah I saw that all
right so you saw the girl Aquafina that
was in it the the Asian co-host where
she was the comedy relief
yes I remember right when it was on when
they was on the bus and she was his best
friend and she was like how come you
didn't tell me that you knew Kung Fu
well she's in the film she's the love
interest of Renfield because she's a
police officer that wants to do well and
she's um she's trying to do the right
thing the whole town is corrupt all the
police are corrupt with this crime
family that's selling drugs and it's
over the top comedy but Nicholas Cage
and everybody kneels it the the action
scenes is akin to John Wick type of
action scenes where you're going to be
amazed at some of the stuff that's done
a lot of hand-to-hand combat a lot of
gymnastic acrobatic stuff very well done
the colors are very well done the music
is very well done the set scenes are
very good Nicholas Cage acting
everyone's acting is on point the
cinematography from beginning to end is
great and I have absolutely zero
problems with the film I thought the
film told a great story of uh being
abused and controlled by a narcissist
and you trying to come out of that and
take back your control take back your
power uh and try to break up in a toxic
relationship because renfell and Dracula
are in a toxic relationship we've never
looked at it from that aspect we didn't
see it like that and it's so dope to see
a different story a age-old story
told in a modern fashion with a new
twist and I'm not gonna lie I think this
is Nicholas Cage one of Nicholas Cage's
best
um
movies since Face-Off
s
I'm very Pro Nicholas Cage like I
actually feel like Nicholas Cage has a
lot going for him and he's a fantastic
actor
yeah yeah sure this this film is dope I
think people can you can name a bunch of
bad Nicholas Cage movies but the problem
is
Nicholas Cage like a lot of people are
very picky when they start to get some
names they're like okay you know what
let me read through 50 50 scripts I
might accept too Nicolas Cage is like
I'm gonna I'm gonna read through 50
scripts and I'm except 45.
and I've noticed that like he's helped a
lot of like Indie developer uh Indie uh
Studios he's helped a lot of b-rated
movies where like he would be like look
I'm gonna come through there and I'm
gonna be pretty chill when it comes to
paying me but I'm gonna take like 30 of
your budget yeah yeah but it helps get
people watching that because he's such a
big name
yeah
um I can't I can't say that Nicholas
Cage hasn't been in a ton of B films
I think it was a time when Hollywood
walked away from um
Nicolas Cage even though he's Francis
for Coppola's grandson uh you know they
uh walked away from him and like left
him in Exile and he made his bones so to
say in the B movies for a long period of
time this is one of those big budget
Hollywood films that he actually got a
chance to do and he did a fantastic job
with um I think this
uh listen Lord of War was really good
right
I I I dare you to go see Renfield and
tell me that this his acting wasn't
better than Lords of War because
Face-Off is probably his Pinnacle to me
Facebook Face-Off is probably his
Pinnacle I believe this film
yeah yeah but I'm telling you his acting
in this this you're going to it's laugh
out loud funny
and it's dead serious which is nuts to
do it
um we have uh ten dollar super jab from
the angry therapist MD Ken stable wanted
to show some love thank you brother all
right so that appreciate that between
the last week and this week what we're
gonna do is I'm gonna get with King
soon and uh you know we'll put something
out uh for you guys I don't know how
we'll do it yet
uh but I I want to start doing some
extra stuff depending on you know
because if people support us go above
and beyond and support us I want to give
them extra content so next week what me
and King will probably do is you know
we'll do like some of the show be right
we'll write Nicolas Cage movies next
week
put a bunch of Nicholas Cage movies
together and we'll write them
that'd be dope but I'm I'm giving this
full popcorn I thought this was a
fantastic film something that I I would
highly recommend
I mean it was so incredible that you
know my wife and I is is watching it and
we are laughing
from you know it it was really good film
really good for everybody in the film
had a good time uh watching this film so
I think Renfield is something that you
should go check out if you have
something to do this week or nothing to
do this week go check it out yeah
definitely go check that out you guys
all right so we're gonna go ahead and
move on uh we we do me so King calls me
this morning he's like I got it I don't
know if we ain't communicating we
watching as a king it's Tuesday
it's it's it's it's one you don't got
time to watch anything he's like just
hit me I'm like well you can watch this
movie named life I just watched or you
could watch beef because I'm watching it
now he's like beef it is I'll see you in
a couple hours
so uh how many episodes did you get
three one so two episodes two episodes
okay I've seen five well I'm going back
up to see the rest of them yeah so
first off I want to really point out
I don't know if it's just me but I feel
like
the the the acting from Glenn from The
Walking Dead is phenomenal in this TV
show yeah you feel a struggle right he
like and it's different because he was
struggling on The Walking Dead but it's
two tiredly different forms trucks
this struggle is crazy like and you know
you you hearing him talking you
generally feel like this man about to
have a like a breakdown are you a
nervous breakdown I thought he's gonna
have a nervous breakdown as soon as the
movie start I mean still the show
started
and they're putting so many elements in
here and you know what I love how they
ended it is he went out he just flicked
her off I thought that was funny yeah
yeah so okay
um I'm up to the the the the last part
the this you know the second episode
um because you're you you might start
blending episodes right so the last
thing is um I saw is after the chairs
and she gets get back on him and he goes
to her house with the hammer all right
so I'm I'm at that part with the house
with the hammer thing but
the First episodes
is it's it's insane because he's waiting
online while this guy is having a
conversation with somebody in line and
he's bringing back some stuff to like
their version of Walmart and he didn't
have his receipt and the guy says you
know you bring back a couple of things
this week or whatever together why he
kept bringing that back and buying it
and bringing it back
no I have not put that together it's sad
I don't know I think in the next episode
you'll find out but I love how they put
that back they're like okay you know
because remember the cashier at the
beginning is like yo why you keep
bringing this bat yeah and then he's
like
you got no questions asked so stop
asking questions
I feel like he was going to cross a
cross he was going to smack that kid
across the counter like but he wanted to
give [__] I felt that energy like he's
about to be like you keep talking [__]
I'ma smack you but he wanted to because
he he had him waiting online while he
was running his mouth with the guy in
front of him I can't stand that intercom
is same yo remember your receipt we
ain't trying to do this remember your
receipt
and that's that's another uh smackable
offense so he gets into a road rage uh
thing
with another car
so he doesn't know and he's assuming
that this is a guy
he's assuming that it's a guy in the car
that cuts him off that
and the person in the car in front of
him
is such a dick pause like he's so it's
yo addict I was sitting up get him get
him get him
you know
we almost fell out we have different
like driving scenarios like
I was thinking do you doing all this
extra stuff because of what because you
because you had a break randomly she
flipped you off like you go you about to
go to jail for this not me I'm usually
like get him you get him I'm in the
whole road rage with him yo when he cut
the grass and ran over somebody's lawn
to cut them off
and and and then she was gonna back up
and and crash with them yeah but all
this stuff is caught on on ring cameras
all across the world
yeah they realistically there's no
reason why they couldn't have found that
and did you love her one of those things
fell out in the middle of the of that
cross section like he he what the dog
said one of them popped out of his truck
oh you're talking about the ones that
fell on the floor yeah yeah
it was funny so but it was more funny
when he remembered the license plate
yeah yeah he kept saying it over and
over again yeah yeah it is it's
interesting man like I I really this is
a unique type of experience I don't
think we've really experienced that much
like it really feels like these two hate
each other and what's funny is they
don't even really know each other like
it's I think I think she I think she was
going to give him the Buns
when he came into the house
and and she she was um she it was funny
she was doing something erotic and she
she says no
yes no she said he's not gonna be back
for a while
like because she was already inside
that's probably why she was so upset
because the only did he do what he did
but then she has that frustration on top
of it you know her frustration is heavy
because as you you start to find out
more more about each character
as The Show Goes On you get to see why
this guy is such a loser
you know he's up 20 grand and you know
his life is cool
his family lost their family business
because of him uh trusting his cousin uh
he's just
they can't get right guy like he's the
hard luck hero who can't get right and
every choice he makes it's wrong
she's the good get right hard-working
came from nothing making her life into
something and she's with a husband who
came from everything and now is like
some Buddhism Minecraft that is driving
her nuts so in her personal life they
Clash I don't even know how they're
together they Clash she wants to do uh
on the edge stuff and her husband is
really reserved and really uh peaceful
and and very very Gap very that he he
strikes me off as very Gap
and
it just doesn't work and her life is a
life of frustration because she's trying
to make it work for her kid
and she said he knows that she's a
frustrated individual and the way that
he talks about her the way that he
portrays her her husband
is like she's this angry individual that
needs to be uh get her life in control
get in control with her feelings because
she's always chasing money
and he comes from money and then the the
mother-in-law is there so her life has a
whole bunch of frustration as well so
you have two frustrated individuals
whose life have come into sect
and the level of Petty from both
individuals are insane what they do to
each other when one is not looking is
Buck bananas they're taking it way too
far this is this stuff has you can't see
nothing criminal Behavior you you ain't
seen nothing you think you've seen that
you ain't seen nothing well I'm I'm
gonna go see her like when I go eat
dinner right now I'm gonna go um
especially homegirl like now because I
believe she did he did his thing and now
she had to get back you don't say yeah
but I got to the part where she
disrespected his vehicle oh
they
hold up
no
did you see that I ended off where he
pulled up to her yeah well she's she's
texting her his brother okay okay you've
seen the catfish thing
yeah he's yeah yeah and then she's
sending the picture and she she does a
whole she makes a whole profile of being
somebody else she thinks she's talking
to this dude
this is she's pretending to be her
assistant yes but I think her assistant
has a thing for her husband and her
husband was liking her assistant picture
it's a whole thing that's going on there
it's it's what's funny is this is the
most realistic drama that you could ever
be across of like like look even though
that their pettiness have went above and
beyond I could still see this happening
yo Dragonheart you'll be said what
you're saying is they bucking up on each
other hell yeah it's wild bucking up
going on I can't wait I can't wait to
see this I can't wait to see the rest of
it say etiquette so far
Eric can sit there and block out time
and do things right me I have to watch
things in chunks because I'm doing a
whole bunch of other stuff
I gotta catch up to him because he's
having too much fun I see it in his eyes
this morning when I was uh doing all the
prediction stuff because we got stuff in
the background file p uh yeah once I
click render I had nothing to do for
like an hour
he was like I just watched an episode
and a half and uh you know uh because
how I do is I render all the shorts at
once so once I make them all I click I
have my computer render them all and
that takes like an hour and a half by
itself
so once I started that then I could
watch another out another episode and a
half but all right so we let's let's not
give it a popcorn rating let's finish
the whole series
we'll give up First Impressions popcorn
rating
okay
first impression so far it's five five
like this is crazy yeah this is if you
know why you know why I gotta give it a
five because I did not expect him to do
what he did to her oh the house
with a wife and husband was arguing and
she was like she was he was like maybe
he just has bladder and she's like he
was smiling when he was running
yo and he is so Zen
yo it's a whole lot of petty the black
John it is
I wasn't expecting this level of petty
you have no idea
how Petty and again this is better it
gets better like the pattern is not
telling me it's getting better
I I I
my wife was asking me let me put it to
you this way there's this one part in
the show I'm not going to spoil anything
home girls on a stage
and she doesn't know homeboy knows where
she is and you're not like one of those
things where you're on a stage and
you're doing like this community thing
where people are asking questions so
he's like I want to ask her something
she can't see him because of all this
sun going on don't say anything this guy
here he I I can't stand that we gotta go
uh attic will blow everything up for me
I just wanted to give you that scenario
where she thinks she's good and then you
just start seeing some dude screaming yo
what he's so paranoid he thought he saw
her in the club
she probably was in the club though but
now now
right now that you think about it she
was in the club
because she told husband I'm going to
the store
yo did you see check it out of the gas
thing I don't know if you got that no no
okay I okay I literally stopped when he
got to her house and he has the hammer
in his hand
that's it all right so check it out
you're going to like it if you're into
Petty get back crap and digging into
people's lives being a voy or being a
fly on a wall checking out individuals
lives this is something to check out
it's something funny I think attic
addict has always uh he's never led me
wrong yet he he has not he definitely
respects his opinion this was his choice
and I'm in it again now again with this
guy all right so that's
guys I appreciate you coming in for the
r r with the Lords talk about TVs movies
and Anime I'm gonna go ahead and wrap
this up uh one thing I do want to point
out again is you know I can't recommend
enough especially the people in the chat
right now especially you gentlemen and
and ladies you know go on there oh
I'm on the wrong thing I'm on the payout
thing for IOP yeah if you go to that
it's going to take you an error screen
go go check out our patreon man I think
you know you guys will like that because
now the patreon has things okay for uh
the five dollar tier you can ask any of
our shows a question
um you know the attic show r r with the
Lord's IOP but I will say the majority
of the patreon is towards r r you know
we have a seven dollar table you can
watch reactions and then we have a 10
achiever you can recommend reactions uh
so I think you guys will enjoy that but
you know I appreciate everyone coming
through here King give you outing our
bars with people find you at
yeah you can find me on Twitter but this
week I'm gonna go see
um the Pope's Exorcist and I'm gonna see
nefarious uh those two movies are out
you have scary movies this whole month
uh and you have like the Evil Dead movie
on the 21st I believe it's it's a ton of
scary movies and I gotta watch them so
I'm gonna have nightmares for months but
gotta check this stuff out I definitely
wanted to see the Pope's Exorcist uh and
I definitely want to see nefarious uh
nefarious is about uh demon that
possesses an inmate and I think a lawyer
goes over to him and he passes the demon
on to the lawyer and forces him to do
certain things and the Pope's Exorcist
is uh a child is possessed and is asking
for a certain Exorcist to to come see
him and he wants the Pope's Exorcist but
there's a whole plot behind that that's
what I want to see and we all know what
the Evil Dead is is a reimagining and
retelling of the Evil Dead story I
believe so I'm going to go check that
just watch that one that's this Friday
um but I'm gonna definitely check out
Mario tomorrow so uh you can find me on
Twitter King David OTW
same name on my Xbox I think maybe we
have a community stream this weekend
this Saturday we have Ryan Garcia versus
Javonte tank Davis in a fight that is
sure to enthuse and definitely amuse I'm
going to be calling that fight this
weekend combat talk with the King 10 p.m
Saturday April 22nd when we get a chance
to see
who's going to win that fight and um I
won't give a prediction until after I
see the weigh-in of both characters I
mean both uh in combatants and I can
definitely tell you from the weigh-in
who's going to win and what round is
going to be what if it's going to go the
distance so if it's going to be a
knockout but uh thank you guys for
rocking out with us see you next week on
RNR with the Lord's 5 PM
and you can catch me on Twitter uh Lord
addictile P catch me tomorrow attic show
with uh dark gray goody five P 5 30 p.m
I gotta remember to say that we actually
have a lot to talk about when it comes
to uh Playstation Xbox Nintendo gaming
in general it's definitely catch me
there uh but I appreciate it for coming
through here now let me go see who we
can raid today you know I'm gonna try to
make a segment where we will we discuss
this because I feel like you know uh I
want to send to someone that actually
can use it like CB gray is my dude but
he's probably got 500 people in there
oh let's send it to CB gray ain't no one
else on you guys go on there if you're a
content creator and enabled where people
can rage you YouTube needs to do a
better job and then explaining that
because I love to send people I mean we
only got 43 people in here but you know
some people have two or three people in
the chat that would love 43 people but
I'm pretty sure for coming through this
is gaming addict and King David and we
are out
peace
[Music]
foreign